sí decisiones importantes justo antes de
terminar este término y que tan Jackson
se posicionará para el término Entonces
es de octubre el término de del otoño
Pero estas decisiones son dos la primera
es el límite que pone la Corte Suprema
de Justicia a la agencia de protección
Ambiental de Estados Unidos que es la
encargada de limitar la emisión de gases
de efecto invernadero gases de carbono
en Estados Unidos Esto entonces limita
mucho más a esta agencia para poner
límites en cuanto a la minería y en
cuanto a empresas que pues son las que
más contaminan de las que más contaminan
en Estados Unidos Esto va obviamente en
contra de la política ambiental y las
promesas que hizo el presidente joeyden
en campaña de limitar la emisión de
gases de efecto invernadero entonces va
a dificultar aún más esta promesa el
cumplimiento de esta promesa y los
logros para limitar los gases de efecto
invernadero y así espectacular el
crecimiento de la temperatura a nivel
Global en un país que es de los que más
emite gases de efecto invernadero y que
quiere jugar un rol mundial de liderazgo
en temas ambientales la segunda decisión
que toma la Corte Suprema que estaba muy
estado el país entero sobre todo en el
sur en la frontera con México estaba muy
pendiente de esta es la decisión de que
ahora sí va a poder el gobierno y El
Ejecutivo yo bailén poder terminar con
la política de quedarse en México estar
una política que había implementado el
presidente Joe biden y que le permitía a
Estados Unidos pues forzar a los
inmigrantes que pedían asilo en este
país a esperar la decisión migratoria en
México y esto entonces pues habilitaría
a que los inmigrantes que están pidiendo
asilo en Estados Unidos esperen en
Estados Unidos y no en México y sea el
Gobierno Federal que decía esto y no los
gobiernos estatales